what a [__] baller I was gonna save
this guy for next week but we're gonna
do a double billionaire of the week so
we're doing a double Billy special get
your get your Billy's right now Richard
Burton okay say have you heard of this
guy Richard Burton is it Burton
Snowboards no so this guy I started a
couple of different companies so it's
just if you're just Google Richard
Burton I did earlier and nothing came up
did I saying his name wrong I think you
got it wrong cuz I did okay he Barton
sorry Barton not Burton okay so Richard
Barton so this guy started Zillow he
also started one of your favorite sites
class door also started he has three so
he has Zillow he has glass door and
what's his other one I was just research
this for next week so we're just gonna
do this live here and he did Expedia he
did Expedia order directors on Netflix
but you did Expedia Zillow and Glassdoor
what a [__] baller like okay yeah
yeah so okay so how did this happen so
I've listened this interview with this
guy like five years ago before this
podcast even started before this podcast
was even a little you know sperm in my
balls and when I when I looked at this
guy the one thing that stood out to me
was he had a very simple thesis that he
used to start all these companies which
was information wants to be free so okay
what does information wants to be free
man so he was basically like I'm gonna
bring transparency to industries that
are better not transparent and so he
said you know let's take Zillow for
example before Zillow when they sort of
online house property and house search
companies existed like Trulia and all
this red fan stuff like that the MLS
listings were something that only the
agents and brokers had access to and so
this is they were gatekeepers they were
like oh you want to know what's on the
market
let me literally print out the MLS
papers and I'll show you they show you
these and all all tore you through these
companies that's so great line dude
information that was an information once
you got information wants to be free and
so so then he did the same thing in
travel right we had travel agents who
were the brokers who you had to call and
be like hey I'd like to get a flight I
don't want
to mention that you just trusted
hopefully this agent is gonna do we were
gonna do their job they're gonna know
all the different options different
times different airports and they're
gonna find me something that fits my
needs and Expedia was just a search bar
that would just tell you here's all the
flights you decide here's the
information you don't need to go to a
travel agent anymore and Glassdoor is
the same thing you wanted to know what's
it really like to work there and
employers have no desire to put that out
there they don't want anybody to know
any of the bad things that happen you
know the working environment of their
company and employees were often scared
to do it because they would sign things
so it'd be like you know non-disclosure
whatever non slander if you're the term
for it is non-disparagement and so
Glassdoor was unleashing the information
about what's it like to work at X
company and so I love how this guy
literally on one thesis has started
three multi-billion dollar companies off
that one premise and so that was when I
when I did what you're talking about I
reverse engineering how did this guy do
it it wasn't oh how did he build Expedia
how did he build illah it was how did
you even get this idea okay what other
industries today lack transparency where
I can open them what are they do well if
now that's a billion-dollar idea I need
to have let's think of some one of them
is pricing for enterprise software right
what is find out how much money your
company makes and then they go okay
we're gonna charge you this right like
that like like I hate that call for
pricing model I mean I I hate it but it
works we do it so AngelList did this in
a way as well when you were able to
figure out who's invested in what that
used to be like sort of not easy to find
information it wasn't sort of like
totally guarded but I crunch mice as
well I'm literally just looking at the
tabs that I have open right like Yelp
yeah I'll put something like that to you
know how was it what is like to eat
there the review system it organized and
made public information that people
wanted that was not super transparent
before this yeah I mean housing he did
that there's a lot there's so many good
ones
um salaries he did that with class door
those last reduce salaries yeah so
there's there's one that I use that's in
the tech world called levels I think we
talked about it what's before but they
do it where with just the like kind of
tech companies it's like what do people
had tech companies make and a lot of
people have been doing this on inside
companies so inside Microsoft for
example they created an anonymous Google
Doc where you could just put your level
your job category like engineer or
design or product person whatever and
your salary your pay and then people
that's yeah you can figure out am i
underpaid but this was even in like more
specific it was like in a company these
are people now like and it's not just
classed over it's like just a few who
kind of go and poke the stuff but there
get like these these companies are
having all these like really rich
documents with thousands of people
contributing in and right now those are
just Excel Docs I wonder if you could
take the just a salary component of
maybe what's in glass door and do it in
a better way
inside company so people make sure
they're not getting the short end of
stick within their own company right now
that's interesting
another one is freelancers so the answer
is what freelancers and agents these so
the problem with a lot of the stuff is
when we're trying to hire some agencies
to WordPress to bail on it I have to
back-channel and go find out from people
who worked with them what they were like
once I sign up to and agree with them I
can't I won't find out unless I'm on a
weekend if they suck or not right I
can't believe I'm in and that's the same
thing with like payroll software to like
gussto looks good but when you sign up
to it you don't realize like what you
like and what about it so we have a
couple friends who are doing things that
are trying to put out you know they're
trying to make information will come
free of what software do companies use
so like a lot of people would want to
know what does the hustle use what do
you guys use to send email what do you
guys use for analytics what do you guys
use for your payment paywall what are
use for trends and like I know Ryan at
producthunt they're doing this with
something called stacks or your stacks
and they want to know what's your
software stack that your company runs on
and it's an interesting idea he's
designing it kind of like a social
network
but the value in the air and if you did
if you get there is oh cool I can now go
see okay if I'm building an Airbnb type
of company what do they use to run their
company what do they usually do you
think that that is not working well it's
really tough to build right it is one of
those things where really valuable if
you get they're really tough to get the
information in because you have to get
the incentives right later on you have
the incentive to come to the site
because you want to see what other
people use but what's the incentive to
post and so he's trying to make it fun
and interesting and cool to post by
making it like very visual like sort of
a get it doing that a profile for your
company right like like yeah we use this
stuff and so I don't know the numbers on
how it's doing but I do think it's an
interesting experiment and I think if
they did it it would be the most
valuable thing that producthunt has
built because it's a it's just
inherently surely there's a great
business model on top of that if you can
show what software people will use
that's cool I agree that's interesting I
love this idea of information needs or
information wants to be free yeah let's
think more about that so I think we'll
come back with an example of information
today that is either behind a walled
garden or it's incomplete
and if you set it free it would make
people make better choices or save them
money or whatever it is like maybe it's
something in the insurance space maybe I
don't I don't know exactly what but I'm
gonna think about this because I think
this is a formula for building really
big companies yeah for me it's how much
things cost like like freelancers and
lawyers and things like that that's it's
always bothered me I don't like I like
my lawyer could be like yeah we charge
$700 an hour and when I was first
getting going I was like have no idea is
that normal
right and on the other side it's also
how much companies make right like you
love it when you hear that a company's
public or it's a non-profit cuz you're
like yes I'm gonna get to their
financials because they have to report
you know yeah well and they do in a
really interesting way and they're owned
by a publicly traded company they do
about a hundred twenty million dollars a
year in revenue what they see is like 25
grand for a pitchbook subscription right
really expensive and they do about 120
they're owned by is it called
Morningstar or
engine right SR I think it this morning
star or morning source like the mutual
fund thing it's yeah it's all about one
of those things and I just rather their
earnings thing morning's target is
morning soccer and they are the mutual
fun thing to and what they do is they do
a bunch of different things the first
thing they do is they crawl the web and
they find SEC documents and they find
like all time they just crawl and find
data and they have a team of like 300
people who just hit the phones all day
and call people and get the information
okay and then the other one that's like
that is you know even for podcast when
we look at the top charts and we're like
alright how do we become the number one
business podcast we don't know how much
you know how many downloads they get
right there's this idea of how much
something is how much is being earned
how much is something making and how
much does something cost I think that
just generally would apply to a whole
bunch of different spaces that you could
you can use for this yeah that's why I
use a similar web because they show me
how much like traffic they guess traffic
one of the dope ones of this do you use
second measure yeah they're great
they're great I think a little bit
extension oh they are yes if you don't
know what they are so second measure
takes credit card spending data and can
tell you essentially like how much money
something is making just by analyzing
how many people are charging Spotify per
month and then I got really cool right
imagine spot if I was not public company
you'd be able to see here's how much
revenue that they're making or they do
this with like the delivery companies
which delivery companies winning well
they can just check this huge data set
of credit card spending and say okay it
looks like grub hubs in the lead and
then second is door - or whatever and so
second measure is super powerful using a
source of truth which just credit card
data all I want to do is like and the
podcast and make my days 50 hours long
and just start a search everything this
whole this whole data or make
information or finding information wants
to be free that whole concept that's
amazing
that's the test I want people to listen
this podcast and be so excited and then
I want you to feel anxious I want you to
feel stress that you don't have 50 hours
in your day to go do this and that's
that's how this should feel I've heard
about people say like yeah I have to
keep pausing the podcast to like a write
[__] down B take a breath C think about
what's going on and then I was
and yeah that's what one set that high
value
[Music]
you